all right it's uh it's sort of feeling
like fall here in massachusetts
which means that in an election year
it's probably
primary day because massachusetts will
sometimes have
very very late primaries and indeed
yesterday september 1st was primary day
here in massachusetts and it was
basically a good night
for incumbents we followed a lot of
these individual races which i'm going
to go through with you which had
prominent primary races in the senate in
the house of representatives
we even interviewed one of the
candidates last week and
overall if you were hoping to see
incumbents upset you did not see it
yesterday so let's go through some of
these races
first and foremost we had incumbent
democratic senator ed markey
defeat challenger joe kennedy the third
joe kennedy iii of course
a congressman who is giving up his seat
in the house we'll talk about who won
the primary for that house seat a little
later
but ed markey winning solidly
55 to 44 with about 1.2 million votes
cast but
still i mean listen all that matters is
who wins in the end
um but 44 for a challenger to an
incumbent democratic senator in the
state of massachusetts particularly one
who's relatively well liked
is not nothing so you know it's like
that when you lose
you've lost and saying joe kennedy can
feel good about 44
it's kind of dumb feel stupid to say it
but this is not
80 20. 55 to 44 ed marky will
uh retain his spot at the top of the
democratic ticket and presumably
will be reelected um in november i did
vote for marky i received questions
about this a number of times during live
calls and for me
what it fundamentally came down to was
the case being made for why
kennedy should replace marky was not a
solid one for me there was the idea
that kennedy is more progressive and
when i looked at the issues particularly
on
climate and in other places i just
didn't see it
and to say let's remove someone who now
has built some seniority in the senate
for someone else basically for what
feels like the argument that he's
younger joe kennedy
39 years old and marky in his 70s
it felt like a weak case and so i
ultimately did vote for ed markey and
that's not a secret i mentioned that on
the program
a number of times before in my uh sort
of
former congressional district because i
i don't live in that area anymore but
also the lines have been redrawn
in any case my former congressman
richard neal the incumbent
uh facing a solid primary challenge
from holyoke mayor alex morse holyoke
massachusetts mayor alex morse i met
alex morris more than a decade ago we
interviewed him on the program when he
was running for and had won
the mayorship of holyoke massachusetts
he was also on the program
last week he did not prevail ultimately
the incumbent richard neal
won it it wasn't super close 59 to 41.
again you can say great job by alex
getting 41 percent of the vote
but it was not really close there was
polling going into this one that said it
was within five
points and the margin of error was a few
points there so
you could argue that there was polling
saying that this was effectively
a statistical tie maybe but in the end
59
to 41 uh there and
richard neal will uh certainly be
re-elected
in november then we had a three-way race
for joe kennedy's vacated seat so this
is the democratic primary
for who will be on the ballot in
november
for joe kennedy's seat which he is
vacating
in order to run against ed markey losing
yesterday of course
and there an incredibly close raise
jessie mermel just barely defeating jake
oshenslaw austin kloss
22.4 to 22.3 now
that was only 105 vote margin incredibly
with becky grossman in third place with
about 17 and a half
percent of the vote uh and then we had
incumbent
stephen lynch one of the more i think is
fair to say
centrist democrats in the house
defeating challenger robbie goldstein
that one even less close
than the alex morris richard neil race
lynch winning 66-34 which is very close
to a two to one margin
so that one was not close although
goldstein did generate
some level of interest and enthusiasm in
the district in
massachusetts now one other primary of
interest yesterday
there's this wacky conspiracy theorist
who was running for the republican
primary for the senate so this would be
which republican will be on the ballot
in november against ed markey
and this doc ayadarai
is a doctor who falsely claimed to
to have invented email spread
disinformation about coronavirus
promoted unfounded covid treatments i
mean really like a wacky
i don't want to say alex jones-like but
certainly shades of alex jones
dr shiva lost the republican primary to
kevin o'connor
60-39 so o'connor will be on the ticket
against marky in november
now to give you a sense of of the
lopsided nature of massachusetts
uh even though republican presidential
candidates get in the high 30s to low
40s right so it's it's lopsided but you
still have a sizable republican
population in massachusetts there were
only 225 000 votes cast
in the republican senate primary
compared to one
more than 1.2 million votes in the
democratic
senate primary and by every indication
ed markey will easily defeat kevin
o'connor in november but you've got to
vote
you've got to vote there's a reason we
don't go by polls and we actually
hold the elections near uh near my dad's
house for the last several months i've
been driving by
a house with a sign that says dr shiva
and i always cringe when i drive past it
i'm hoping it's going to be taken down
very very soon but overall
some of the latest primaries leaning in
the direction of the democratic
incumbents
some more progressive some less
progressive
and we now know who will be on the
ballot uh in november
uh joe biden leading overwhelmingly here
in massachusetts some polls say
it's a lead in the 20s high 20s some
leads some polls say it's a lead in the
30s
for joe biden but we've got to run up
the score
every massachusetts voter should vote we
must run up the score and in fact
that's sort of what i want to talk about
next